hey guys welcome back to brand-new video
back on for honor gun for another video
and just now the for honoured team just
released a trailer for the for honor
past present and future video which
basically highlights what for honor has
done since release and how it's improved
but at the end they showed this clip now
obviously this is just speculation but
for honor could possibly have a new hero
or faction coming to the game the map
looks like it takes place in a desert
and the enemy looks like he's moving a
scimitar which person soldiers are
typically are stereotypically known for
using so my guess is either we're going
to be getting a new Persian hero or a
new Persian faction to be added into the
whole realm of the other three factions
and to be honest either one is
completely fine with me
more information is probably going to be
found out about at e3 so definitely
stick around on the channel for that
I'll give you guys all up-to-date on
what's going on because there's no way
that they're not going to show this at
e3 now that they've just teased this
they can't do us like that I'm very
interested to see what the new here if
this is a new here on what his moveset
would be whether if he has some other
type of weapon maybe he has two schema
tars only one what its gonna look like
what class is gonna be anything like
that I'm super excited to let you guys
know this once I figure out these info
when they releases at e3 as I said very
short video today guys let me know in
the comments what you guys think about
this your thoughts or ideas that started
discussion in the down in the comments
below I'd love to know everything you
think about this and with that guys it's
gonna be the end of the video today like
that if you do enjoy it subscribe if
you're new I cover the leaks the
informational site a foreigner that
being leaks balance notes patch notes
new updates any new information coming
to the game I like to keep everybody up
to date with my two most recent videos
are gonna be on screen if you guys want
to check that out with that guys hope
they progressed your day let me know
what you guys think about this new
Persian here or faction and peace out
guys and thank you for watching the
video